we have some space that's a good picture
though no because you know what it is is
then if you're sitting there then we
have to [ __ ] be like that it's it's a
consistent angle thing it's definitely
an angle thing all right we going hey
what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for a very special edition of the
Monday morning podcast I didn't know
when the [ __ ] I'm going to put this out
probably before Monday because my guest
his series is already three episodes in
and he was supposed to be on two weeks
ago and I completely spaced big
Hollywood phony that I am and very
fitting that he came back again in the
name of his show was the return of the
Mack as he's returning to the podcast
ladies and gentlemen Joe McIntyre thank
you sorry man oh it's okay I knowing you
I know that you were you told you feel
bad about it so I can you made me feel
worse because you were a [ __ ]
sweetheart ah I was going like Joe can
you least get mad at me like I'm fine I
needed because I needed to get out of
the house yeah says that no I was I was
hanging it was all good dude it was all
good and thank you thank you and I know
I know that you know I'm that you don't
have a lot of guests you know what I
mean so it's special so thank you for
vision I'm [ __ ] guilt trip dude do
you not see your wife I said brutal now
I know you know you're gonna be looking
at other people and it's kind of a
Boston thing too you know what I mean
because we were good with the guilt
thing you know what I mean so we can we
can just let that thing hang over your
head forever you know what I mean for
years and years and years but end up or
not I'll do that because I wouldn't have
seen your show
exactly cuz I was you know I was busy
doing a bunch of [ __ ] right and then I'm
sitting there I had like a panic attack
I'm like oh my god like I [ __ ] stood
this guy up I says no B I wasn't then I
go now I gotta watch your shows like
what if I don't like it
oh how [ __ ] brutal is this like half
hour 45 minutes gonna be fortunately I
watched it and it's [ __ ] hilarious
man Thank You Man really funny Q thank
you they I know I I've got a few friends
that said that like who's literally
gonna say they don't like it but it is
good it is good you know when you you
make something you kind of all in it and
to get some perspective and actually see
it on a
you know a TV and it's it's nice I feel
certain a lot of you know it's a sense
of accomplishment and what what I
couldn't find what network is it on
because we record the thing though it's
on it's on pop TV it's not on the comfy
Channel next time a comfy chair that's
it channel within the show yeah yes on
pop TV which is it's a CBS Lionsgate
partnership but it's it's the channels
been up for about two years it's on most
I think every carrier has it sometimes
it's on like a you know a higher tier so
it's not basic which is kind of a bummer
sometimes so you know on one sense you
know there's not a ton of expectation
you know I mean you can build and
hopefully the network's like yeah we'll
wait you know it's gonna it's gonna
build it takes a second but I'm crazy
though I'm like you know we were coming
up it was just you could find shows yeah
and now it's like you know my parents my
parents have never seen my show because
it's on Netflix and they don't know how
to get on it and so I mean you gotta
have a password yeah you got to like
grab the other remote control do this
yeah they have no idea that's why when I
take my specials they come to the
special because I know they're not going
to be able to find it once I guess on
Netflix so just you know that's the only
way they see it I do I do tweet you I
mean I do text you when I see that
beautiful mug of you on Billboard's
across Los Angeles and then you treat me
a picture of me and like Big Bopper and
in 1988 you don't I mean just together
you always give me [ __ ] though yeah well
you know I got away you know you go we
get it you got a special what the [ __ ]
that's the way you come at me which is
why I was surprised that when I didn't
show up that you were still uh yeah yeah
so he's uh going back how are you
originally met Joe was we worked on a
movie called the heat yes believe it or
not that was up coming up on five years
ago already we filmed it five years ago
and we had a great time on that and
another one of your cast members Jenny
Denbo was on that thing yep on return to
the Mack yes um we that was that was
sweet I mean that gig was sweet Paul
fake movie big movie you're in our
hometown
oh yeah I said the Nate Corddry who was
in it as well
recently I said it's known as three
weeks in August like that yeah it has
its own name you know it was a line or
thing yeah yeah it was lovely it was a
lovely experience and obviously when did
he leave Boston um well I was in New
York for a while you know I I realized
after new kids broke up you know I woke
up when I was like 21 and I was like the
biggest decision I had to make was where
I was having lunch and I was like okay I
gotta I gotta do something yeah I mean
like and wait that that whole thing
broke up you took the whole ride and was
done by the time you were 21 oh yeah
yeah I mean I was 15 when we had our
first hit record so that was like 88 and
then we had like you know four or five
years and then Kurt Cobain came along
and it was on that was it
it was also a where does then it started
back up again yeah in the late nineties
thousand eight well you know what Kurt
killed himself but yeah I wasn't there
to stop those boy back then okay right
yeah exactly
uh no we yeah we've been back together
since 2008 but our fans have grown up
you know what I mean we look back on
that but you know with with an open
heart and the nostalgia and all that
stuff when we embrace it and right now
we're just like a girls night out for
our fans you know they get to get away
from it but yeah you kind of touch on
that in the show where I noticed that
you have like you keep having these
really awkward moments where these like
with that overly like yeah next up women
you know yeah question oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah 50 or yes yeah that's true does
that happen to you a lot like they want
to give you a long little too long of a
hug I don't want you to [ __ ] on your
fans and I know yeah yeah we have all
you know shapes and sizes there's a few
there's a few that if you something to
running for office yeah you're gonna get
in trouble and yeah I got wonderful to
me you know they're back you can't blame
me that we're still playing arenas so
like you say I gotta take care of my my
fans absolutely not say the right thing
but know some some are a little too
little too uh you know aggressive or you
know touchy feely you know I mean but
that's okay for the most part they're
they're part of the job right yes but
but I so so I left so I spent some time
in New York and then I've been out in LA
for
fifteen years and are kind of getting
itchy for the to go back to go back east
dude you know it's it's the best here
but it's funny when I when I think of my
friends who you know have a baby to get
you know you got it how would you yeah
one five three months three months okay
little over and it's hopeful you know
what I mean it's really funny is like in
you know not to get all you know it's a
tough time in the world and it's crazy
whatever but and it's so cliche but it's
like really hopeful someone has a baby
yeah because for you it's all about that
kid man yeah I mean what's more hopeful
than a new kid you know you're just like
you know and it's it's really nice my
kids are yeah almost six seven and nine
so it's a little bit of a different vibe
right anyway some I don't know we feel
like you know what I feel like weird
about how once I left all of a sudden
bale to every team starts winning
championships but as so much fun it is
to be behind enemy lines like Celtics
beat the Lakers I was out here in Red
Sox beat the Yankees I was in New York
but you know I recently did a show and
an acting gig actually one day back in
Boston and I remember the Bruins were
just starting to playoffs and was
looking at my hotel window and I just
saw a sea of Bruins jersey and just to
finally be like oh my god I could
actually wear because I don't wear any
my [ __ ] out here just people that nuts
on the west coast yeah they take it to a
whole other level
it's it's it's violent yeah it's not fun
like when I was in New York was fun it
was ball breaking I don't have been in
Philly and you know as much as they hype
those guys up it's like you got to go
out of your way to really get an ask if
you're definitely going to get [ __ ] you
might get something dumped on you but
that's as far as it goes but out here
yeah it's just like it's like Mad Max
yeah you're a little scared for your
life yeah I mean I was at the 2010 when
the when the Lakers did beat the Celtics
and I was only called 58 fouls on the
Celtics in like 12 on it that's great
that's great for a game yeah yes fun to
watch the Lakers beat us from the foul
line that's a yeah that's always good
for who and they barely won you're right
even without our Center but I'm not
saying we would have won but I'm just
saying it's like you gotta let you gotta
let them play let them [ __ ] play
was anticlimactic than the one memorable
moment from that game that I can only
remember was Ron Artest hitting at 3
that was a [ __ ] huge shot yeah but any
would hardly other than that it was an
ugly game yes there was no magic with
the baby skyhook there was always like a
moment bird steals the ball is something
like that was like nah they just uh
Kobe didn't have a good game that game
you know I'm not saying after the game
he's like I can't I don't know how we
won that game it's like well [ __ ]
talk to the footlocker guys because
those are MVPs they switched out the
footlocker guys with it you know there
were a battery to rub now the last
Boston Cleveland game not Cleveland game
sorry who the [ __ ] we playing both the
bull yeah now the last last Bulls game
like I thought the officiating was
terrible and it was in our favor and I
loved when Lopez did this like the
sarcastic oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was when you then you saw then they
went down the court Dwyane Wade got a
ticky tack another one and he was like
laughing going like no one it was like a
make up call but it was like too late at
that point so died right all right um
good Sarah I mean we got the luck of the
draw there with Rondo getting hurt
Serrano's the MVP the series I think
even does even still yes oh because he's
still the most valuable because he's got
her game it looked like they were going
to sweep but nobody thought it wasn't
gone I know I know I'm back he was in
his out you think he is I think that
he's well make six games fast as off
okay he's got long sleeves on his sport
coat again i tripping anybody named chip
uh uh what's his name crowded crowded
thank you I thought when he tried to act
like he was stretching he was totally
like looking right at him I thought it
was funny and then he says in the press
comedy yeah I got a co and I just like
to stretch it next question and he was
when he $5,000 and he goes he was really
way out of bounds he tried to put on him
yeah yeah that's a fact a deadpan face I
actually I liked I thought it was funny
it was not I mean I don't never should
have money when a guy you guy was gonna
break his [ __ ] leg over that he sort
of stuck it out he he's the kind of guy
you want on your team but he's not a
team anymore right and and then he tried
to push you know Ray Allen out of the
big did he did you see that story where
did they haven't like a reunion a
10-year reunion for the Celtics but like
a year earlier or something like that
they're all
homens or something like that and they
didn't invite ray allen because he went
to the Miami Heat
you know something I never understood
that too because it was like him going
to Miami Miami Heat that's how we got
him he was a sonic yeah right yeah so if
you sign a free agent like an you it's
like I've joked in my pockets that's
like falling in love with a stripper
yeah there's no loyalty at that point
it's just like [ __ ] I'm gonna get paid
and try to win rings and he obviously
was there three four years I mean it
just to me it's a personality thing
that's what I love about sports the most
like you can talk about the X's and O's
and all that stuff but like the
personalities man I mean you look at
LeBron like for me the way it is and how
they sit and why they sit and why they
rest and should they you know they
gettin paid millions and millions and
millions of dollars in there sitting
there rather it's like oh well they're
tired well the other team's tired too
you know so it's a and I just love that
I just think he's like LeBron is I call
him the greatest player ever to not want
the ball at the end of the game no that
was him before before they wanted when
he won he's on the hill doesn't want the
ball at the end so I'm not saying he's
not amazing he does not want the ball at
the end of the game I Kyrie Irving does
I thought he'd pushed through that when
he was with the heat he won he won if he
can go that he won he won I am mad don't
ya know but he just yeah it's a it's it
I you know I'm not hating on him I think
he's an amazing you know athlete and
person and all that stuff I just think
he doesn't all the greats Larry Bird I
say Thomas Kobe and all those Jordan of
course they wanted the ball everyone get
out of my way that's not him and it's
it's intriguing to me yeah I thought he
was that until like once he wanted with
the heat and all of a sudden a member he
was playing some game was the end of the
game and he actually took the shot and
missed but the fact that he did it I
thought that he pushed through he got
mine through he came into the league at
18 I just think there was all this
expectation that type of thing I think
it took him a minute
yeah to kind of grow into it but I think
I think he's he's plastic then you take
the last freaking shot to
it last year no that wasn't it no no he
ran down he blocked the ball no I met
exactly but that's what he'll do well no
was he supposed to take a whole court II
don't know but he overcompensates in
these superhuman ways with that block
but it he does know what the ball I've
never seen a guy so good get so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know what it is
well some people might think I'm hating
on him I'm saying you just called one of
the greatest defensive plays and when
the biggest moment of the biggest
[ __ ] game yes as underdogs he turns
it on you said it was overcompensating
come back well he that's hatin a little
bit I'm go he makes up for not wanting
the ball at the end of the game I can't
listen if he takes the ball and gets it
on the buzzer beater I'll be thrilled
I'll be thrilled
I'm not hating I'm not saying he's not
capable you won't be thrilled if he
doesn't answer Celtics you wouldn't to
me it's fascinating that someone that
talented still has room to grow or our
stuff they haven't done all right that's
unfair enough okay Joe back to my TV
show back to you know I mean I'm getting
this kidding how much of that is improv
ah not a lot actually
no no it's not right thank you yeah i
co-created it with my friend Paul
Greenberg who I was introduced to by
Donnie Wahlberg and Jenny McCarthy who
are also on the show oh yeah hilarious
yes yes they're executive producers as
well so Paul and I and then there was
Heather Rutman and Mike Glock our
writers and so it was a small writing
team but you know you have three days to
shoot so you don't really have a lot of
for each episode
wait you shoot that in three days three
days well how many so can we do two
episodes at a time so it's over six days
we do two episodes so yeah we have uh do
we have three no we had two cameras it
with me and I'm along in your days such
super long because that gets into
overtime and that's a budget thing too
but I've learned a lot of sue there's no
showing it right yet so I'd like to take
you to shoot six so us Oh six you mean
six episode balance well we did eight
episode today so it was a three it was
24 days it was 20
four days and uh which is I I love it I
mean that's [ __ ] great you want more
you know be nice to have you know more
money you say oh it's fine and I want
more but like maybe if there's a second
season you want a little bit more dough
to do this so they do that but as far as
an actor and getting out there you don't
need that much time you know you have
four or five - I never felt like we
didn't have enough time to get the takes
but your point about you know at you
know ad-libbing or improving we didn't
have a lot of time to just go there so
the scripts were good I grade I was
really happy with them and and um you
know it is a little bit here and there
but for the most part I was scripted
yeah yeah that's the way to do a show
I've been it worked with a few people
that knew like the only Sonny guys those
guys like you ever seen how they they'll
shoot this season like they have it all
mapped out so they're like do for like
the whole season like all the bar things
and they're just there yeah shoot it all
run out change and they just do like
it's genius how they do it and then
there's other shows that you go on and
it's just like you're doing like 14 16
hour days and like you literally want to
kill III I don't know yeah paint dry
yeah yeah and I was just like I don't
think I ever won another acting gig in
my life this is [ __ ] horrific and I
always called like those types of shoots
like people say one of those things like
I've said compared it's like going to
the DMV with like famous people so you
just sitting around the same you're
sitting there thinking you're never
going to get called and when you finally
do your [ __ ] elated and it's I don't
know I've heard like stories of like
actors like learning how to play
instruments just sitting I'm waiting in
there yeah it yeah and I know it's like
yeah you hate to complain about a gig
but it's true you're in it you're in a
you're in a trailer and you're in your
sights same thing it's like this is what
I work for like this is what I want and
and it's not one thing a little work
like I want to get there and work
exactly for some [ __ ] reason sitting
around in it's it's I actually
understood my dog better like I get why
with my dog it's just laying there it
goes to sleep because your body's really
like I well we are doing [ __ ] yeah let's
save up this energy and you start
nodding off like an old man and the
second you start to sleep you're going
to get that knock on your door now you
fell asleep you're not going
[ __ ] in it and they bring you IRA
gone but go quickly losing light yeah I
like it yes it's more like a mentally
look it's way better than [ __ ]
roofing in June and July exactly
I lasted like three weeks doing that
[ __ ] but I'm just saying like you notice
to me it's the frustration is when
you're there it's like it doesn't have
to take this [ __ ] long yeah no it
doesn't but that's you know what you
doing it doesn't have to take this
[ __ ] long lighting stuff and
everything in it and I guess you can't
see the difference in some you know the
production value and and that's fine but
I agree and and that's why it's it's in
my nature to go you know what I mean I
got lucky a lot of people trying to make
TV shows in this town and like I'm super
grateful but like I I was like I wanted
to get active and do it and we were able
to get it done and yeah but word gets
out that you know people see how funny a
show is and that you guys shoot it that
quick yeah I don't think you'll have a
problem getting people doing guest on I
think so I think so I'm gonna quote you
Bill there you go you just set yourself
up and plus you think I don't know what
I did there it is you know what to see
you're shrewd businessman you waited and
Adam to kill Adam loves you by the way
Adam Ray as so many do but he was on the
you you guys just did a charity gig and
he went on before you and I think you
were like this guy you know you were
very covered like this guy should have
closed what am i doing it was gotta that
was the video with April foolishness
exactly exactly yeah exactly so yeah
yeah he [ __ ] murdered yeah he's he's
he was it it's one of those things we
say I I wrote for that person like when
I wrote the the the first pilot like I
was just frightened for him you know
what I mean I was just getting off on on
his whole vibe he's super charming guy
loves I mean works a ton and and and we
had a blast doing good you guest stars
to I saw it like the third episode Joey
Fatone joy but the murder yeah yeah yeah
then he's he's a funny bastard so I
daddy I didn't leave silly doesn't he
doesn't like it just exactly
self-deprecating huh and then the Crisco
Patrick who's also from NSYNC he comes
in at the end of episode three and he he
really throws himself under the bus you
know normally you have a guest
and you gotta let them win you know what
I mean yeah but he comes up in Episode
five and he really you know goes for it
so I said you have all these guys on it
and it's great because that you let them
do what they're going to do so you get
to see how town like Joey Lawrence
murdered it yeah I know he was great
again yeah he's sort of like America's
Sweetheart but I knew a different side
of him a real ballbuster like acerbic
super funny he's super talented been
around forever but I knew when we went
at it you know doing that thing it will
be you know super funny and he was great
we had a blast doing it too so now is
that true did you guys both come in
third place we did we did so the thing
is I I want people most a lot of people
forget because I did the first season of
Dancing with the Stars and I didn't want
to do it then I wanted to be I take me
through that okay you're sitting there
you need a gig this is like an episode
of your show and your aging halls up
like Jo totally I got a guy got it yeah
so it was just after pilot season
actually I just did six months on
Broadway in wicked very early on with
idina menzel like you know excite of
like what I what I love to be doing but
I had it in my mind like a rookie I'm
gonna go out to LA and book a pilot all
right just to book a pilot just for my
ego not because of the work not because
of the right project you know what I
mean so I was in it for the wrong
reasons
what's opal open to seeing you for stuff
yeah I mean about a year or so before
that I was on a David Kelly show as a
regular on Boston Public that lasted for
about three years I was on it for a year
it changed my life I came out to LA I
met my wife so thanks a fair like you
needed you needed you had to get one of
those gigs to separate you from all this
guy and a band band the whole thing and
I just thought it would you know change
my life or whatever I'd be cool my ego
just I thought that was it it was
Artemis and so I had a bad you know
pilot season as you know so many I've
been you know what I mean everybody does
now I know now I know everybody no
matter how good you are you know what I
mean like it's a it's it's a crapshoot
so I get this call for dancer this
British guys like it's a beautiful it's
unbelievable
woods it had some other name in the UK
and it's gonna be great and you know
don't worry you'll win and that whole
thing and and we want to make you look
bad yeah I was like great for your
career exactly and I was like I said no
a million times and then I said yes and
no and yes and no and literally I'm up
in my bed over how long a period of time
is all these males and yes maybe a week
or two
the agonizing are agonizing right
because this is not what I want to do I
don't want to do a reality show we
didn't know what Dancing with the Stars
and it's all relative some people I'd
talk about this and they go what's wrong
with it it stands in with the stars it's
it's the biggest show on TV but to each
his own you know it's not what I wanted
to do but anyways I bet I was up in bed
I was like after I almost like Sonic and
I was like I can't do it because I was
in you know the joke is like I get up in
bed and I'm like I'm in a dance contest
with Evander Holyfield look what the
[ __ ] am i doing what am i doing and and
I just couldn't say no and house was on
that season uh Rachel Hunter um whatever
we're on O'Hurley John O'Hurley from J
Peterman we talked about that in my show
in Episode two and uh another girl from
General Hospital and I'm blanking so so
they were all they were all a mess I was
a dancer so they had to take me down
it's a produced show so they're going to
cut me out at the knees from day one to
get the storylines going you know what I
mean so wait so I went how did they take
you out on the show so all these people
all the dancers you can visit what the
[ __ ] you've been doing your whole life
showing that was awful you look like
it's got me surrounding a rally dance
floor they said good oh yeah yeah they
say murdered me murdered me and I wait a
minute - yeah so now how did you hold
you can put like like you're standing
there the filming or the tape I mean
right now but yeah I need not like it
he's mine [ __ ] I don't want you to
try on but oh no I don't care I don't
care all right at this point I mean it's
a joke now I'm and that's why I was able
to use it in the show like the guy I got
Scott miss yeah yeah yeah literally but
and so you know I I'm attached from it
now and and and I'm able to use that
stuff for my show like the guy I play on
my show now returning the Mac is is is
that guy you know what I mean who
couldn't say no who didn't have the
patience or the integrity or the
discipline to write it out for the right
part now I like watching your show
because I see this other side like your
home life and stuff yeah even you get in
like the the person to help with your
kids yeah yeah yeah yeah and that [ __ ]
that I do I know honey whoever you what
do you want fine that's right fortune
you know that's worked out of my life
yeah I mean yeah exactly until until you
know you get some crazy guy and then you
way indefinitely until till your wife
gets it wrong yeah whatever you need so
what the hell were you thinking you know
but I mean I interrupted a great source
you know so you're sitting there they're
saying you're like a scud missile all
over the place I just didn't want to do
the show but it was six episodes people
still go why don't you do Dancing with
the Stars and I think to myself should I
tell him I did it whatever cuz like it
my ego says I like when people forget
that I did that show cuz it's not really
what I wanted to do right on the other
side it's like hey it's all showbiz
right in in life things happen and you
learn from them how many how many weeks
did you do well it was only six weeks
back then because it was the it was a
summer program they were giving it a
shot by six weeks the finale there was
like 15 million people watching it so
and 15 million people so you come in
third yes and we did you lose to Evander
Holyfield he know I beat Evander
Holyfield a yeah was not a lot of people
to say that yeah off man but just but
but but but
exactly he's a good but John John
O'Hurley loved it guys in his 60s he's
doing the walls he's eating it out
they're loving and he's eating the
scenery you don't I mean my god bless
him this was obsessing in his light a
spark in your eyes I haven't seen her
year exactly it was brilliant and good
for him you know what I mean he had a
blast and and I learned a lot too I mean
I learned you know how to do that kind
of dancing and you learn from the
dancers and dancers in this business
especially on Broadway are the
hardest-working people in show business
because they got a dance
you know most of them have to sing on
Broadway they dance and sing their egos
are like totally in check they they come
to work every day they don't complain
and it's the stars and the leads that
you know do all the complaining when
they really have it's so much better
than everybody else right yeah Wow yeah
so what was the fallout of that so after
that uh you come in so how did you take
me we relieved when he got kicked off
the show at that point we just i was
going i think i got episode 5 i was gone
and then they had me back for the finale
everybody was there for the finale um
you know III felt like I went out you
know I I was good with my performances
but again they they took me down because
they needed a storyline I mean that's
kind of what that that's my story
anyways but um it was cool I mean I
actually did a standards album after
that and we went on tour and we I feel
like I got a little something out of it
you know to me we weren't on like an
arena tour and funny enough that
actually that's how I met the new kids
manager at the time we were managing and
I talked to Donnie Donnie and I were
talking about getting together and I
said well this might be the manager
because I've been working with this guy
so it's that kind of thing you do things
that you think are right but you're
there you make the most of it and it
could lead to better that led to you
guys getting back together
well a small piece a lot of things have
to happen you know what I mean stop
nervously you went putting that thing
back together like gonna clock of 40
people going to show up yeah well the
cool thing was that we were we were in
it together I mean it we were if these
other four guys were willing to get in
the foxhole and see what happens because
we have so much history together and
we're like family you know what I mean
so that was a cool part you know what I
mean and I trusted those guys I mean
Donnie you know I felt like he always
held our what we had very dear to woman
like when when MTV or vh1 ago come on
our challenge come on our awards show
they wanted their big ratings hit they
wanted their five minutes and we always
like hey man we're bigger than five
minutes
you know they mean and sure enough the
timing was right and we did it the right
way and our friends showed up for us and
you know we back in arenas after you
know tell you guys didn't even wait
- right here we're doing family Park
July 8th again don't it again yeah cool
yeah so cool that's great cool that's
right so we got you got five more
episodes coming out yeah so you're gonna
get back to Boston uh what's your deal
man are you going to like stay out here
oh that you don't know I know well we'll
see we'll see about the you know second
season you know how that goes but um I
don't know I don't know if I'm just
distracting myself by saying I want to
like get back to New York or Boston
it's so nice out here you actually have
like a yard you know I mean in New York
it's just a totally different thing my
wife's from New York but it's high-class
problems but I'm just kind of like I
don't know if I'm just need something to
chew on
you know what I mean everyone like do
relax you know I mean just you're here
be where you are you know that right
rather than get no [ __ ] answer yeah
that's definitely a definitely issue I
have like my wife freaks out about that
just kinda like can you just sit down
yawn watch TV with you and then if I
watch TV it becomes interactive and I'm
like talking to it and she's just like
you're ruining all of my show and you
have to live yeah I mean that's yeah I
like shut up or leave the room because I
can get very you know like Parenthood
she loved Parenthood and I get it it was
a very successful show but like you know
I would yeah I would tear it apart yeah
like it go you mean that's all I do she
knows my wife I mean she's actually
could come on the podcast because she
kind of went rogue on me you know
there's just there's a rule with like
recording shows yeah where there's the
hey I take the game you don't give a
[ __ ] hey you've got the Real Housewives
of who gives a [ __ ] I don't care but the
good shows the far goes the better call
Saul's we got your show right now it's
like you know these are the other shows
with what there's like with the kid this
is like our shared family time right
dude she watched a better call Saul
[ __ ] erase the thing yeah and then
tries to go oh you can go on to wherever
Wow
yeah and I went Wow yes that's no be
discussing that not you're bringing her
in for that one yeah I was just sitting
there going like way down yeah like what
on is there somebody else you see in
here huh what's good I thought this was
like a together thing that's how it
starts
that's how it's done yeah that radios
your first hint that there's a problem
we have marriages the shows you used to
watch together all of a sudden it's just
like like did you just stop taping that
did you wanna know it was upside was the
Fargo one she watched like the first
episode of the second episode and she
just erased it a mistake was it because
it was like the lowest priority thing no
no no it was because she has gone rogue
is it in TV yeah and I love that you
have in that reaction because it's
priming the pump for the next yeah every
might call the next episode wow wow wow
my wife wow that's so that that's why I
was looking at so that's how it is yeah
so it is I guess I'm on my own now so
the baby thing is it the like she's you
know kind of you know she kind of said
it was that she was just like look you
go out in the road you doin your gigs
yes just like I'm home here I'm tried
yeah okay I need to look at some adults
googoo gaga so long and I am so
sleep-deprived when you're not here oh
you know I just you know delete yes yeah
you know robot mode in bed oh did I dry
it right why sure whatever go on Netflix
and find it
oh I'll take it Nate I would sleep
that's how she looks at it so anyways so
let's let's get the schedule here Kate
you got you can wear can make people
watch wall but right now it's just it's
I wish you know we were on some other
you know what do you call the Netflix in
the hulusi sozin Oh what are you say
that Amazon not yet right now cuz it's a
it's a it's a own channel so we want to
get people to you know go to pop but
it's it's it's pop TV you can go to
poptv.com and throw in your zip code if
you want to find out what your channel
is but it's it's basic for a lot of them
sometimes it's a higher tier so
unfortunately you got it you might have
to dig a little bit but it's on pop TV a
lot of people have it it's on all the
carriers by night what nights Wednesdays
at 8:30 on pop TV and for for another
five episodes and so to get people
caught up yeah he's trying to make a
move they hitch him a talk show yeah you
want to do it yet people get in your
head yeah now you're doing it I have and
I do and people make no major decisions
without without your all Yente that
seems to be a running theme I'm glad
London on that pulling the rug out from
under me at every every moment yeah we
got your sidekick and now all caught up
and now they've decided that it's not
going to be a comedy no now they're
gonna go more I'm not honey she tells me
I'll get the idea the reason why it's we
got it now I've heard it out and oh
you're not funny
you'd like to say I put that up being
like going on stage and like
deliberately bombings hard yeah yeah
you've been like did you just
automatically have the saver like well
that didn't work at least getting
chuckle I think I did that thing about
pixie sticks I don't know for some
reason it was just that thing like you
know that that line you know people have
an idea of what stand-up is and yeah I
go twos and for some reason mine was
remember pixie sticks yeah what's up
what is that stupid like and you think
it's gonna be funny and it's not so I
just love how it never had a payoff I
mean nothing does anybody need that much
sugar yeah it's just one set up after
another and you just [ __ ] go with it
I was this like oh my god I've literally
been the calm oh man that is people's
ideas say everybody has like getting at
the ideas of the boyband
take you know it's just that the other
thing actor and when they see the actual
work of it so right right shall we thank
you alright to happen I really hope it
gets to work again was great to get to
know you on the heat once again I I
apologize for round I'm going to use it
for all it's worth belt it works out
this this hidden episode water figure
return of the Mack thank you for coming
in and continue successfully a great
show you too alright